il reçoit maintenant lucien bouchard qui
a été premier ministre du québec de 1996
à 2001 bon sens monsieur bouchard
d'abord votre réaction à ce décès de
monsieur landry de garder un ami
beaucoup de situations le voyait venir
évidemment quoi quand vous vivez plus
tôt qu'on ne le pensait on perd un ami
on perd un compatriote
on perd un homme peut-être un modèle de
conviction des baladeurs chez lui quand
vous êtes arrivé à québec monsieur
bouchard vous en avez fait votre bras
droit vous lui avez confié de très
grosses responsabilités qu est ce que
vous avez vu en monsieur l'année j'ai vu
un pilier pour moi un pilier politique
j'ai vu un homme de réflexion un homme
engagé et choteau un homme loyal je fais
le pari de la loyauté et parce que je
vais confier beaucoup de pouvoir
religion de la ville 2007 et vice
premier ministre m et des finances et
industrie et du commerce
mais je mange pas trompés parce que nos
liens sont renchéris et bernard
offensive je regarde l'objet quelqu'un
qui se trouvait au coeur des années les
plus jeunes tranche de ma vie ma vie en
finale
j'aimerais qu'on a vécu est
extraordinaire c'était des grandes
années pour la cause souverainiste et et
pour la mobilisation politique quand on
fait un référendum il ya quatre plus ni
92% a déjà acquis par m imaginez le taux
de participation qui m'a dit que tout le
monde était été interpellés d'un côté ou
de l'autre mais tout le monde sait ça
aucun geste de violence ça revient de
digérer cieux tout ça dans l'expression
des droits civiques et démocratiques
tels qu'on les conçoit et bernard était
un démocrate en arrêter quelqu'un qui
croyait au débat il croyait aux idées
qui croyez pas du tout à la violence
citoyen vient section pour
j'ai décidé de maintenir des liens de
respect entre les acteurs politiques et
avec les citoyens alors jamais fait
oublier bernard parce que il est
intimement lié ma carrière politique
d'abord et surtout à ce qu'on a vu ici
affaire enfants je peux le faire des
choses ensemble qui était pas facile on
était dans une situation de redressement
des finances publiques
on coupait beaucoup dans beaucoup de
budgets importants qu'en même temps on a
été capable de créer beaucoup de
programmes sociaux la shoah ce
médicament à l'équité salariale économie
sociale les politiques familiales et
garderie
on fait beaucoup de choses en même temps
il les abordait lui justement si les
jeunes a été difficile pour lui au final
puisque l'autre qu'ils doivent trouver
l'argent pour faire tout ça là rien pour
rétablir l'équilibré et même pour faire
des shows plus il leur revient pour
lancer ses nouveaux programmes sociaux
et il était au coeur des circuits libres
a assuré disant piquetage qu'il fallait
faire au sein de l'état et puis en même
temps on peut pas penser qu'on ne refait
chaque et les débats internes les débats
très vifs
autour de la table des ministres de
l'année caucus et même au sein du parti
libéral est toujours été extrêmement
solide dans la promotion de ce programme
qu'on a poursuivi en somme des 6 026
euros
il vous a fait quand même très grande
place quand vous êtes arrivé à québec
parce que lui même avait de grandes
ambitions gagner la place qu'ils
voulaient prendre humain
bernard était dans droite par d'espérer
surtout à ce moment là de vide qui
s'ouvrait la combler il lui même de
devenir 1er mai le chef du parti
il n'y a pas fait de drame mais pas fait
des crises de nerfs il m'a lui-même
appelé il m'a dit du chien si tu te
présentes à la tête du parti
je veux tu as pu errer je n'y serai pas
de la course par contre tu me diras tu
toi j'arrête parce que moi je vais un
être normal alors cherché une façon très
civilisée très conviviale mais et après
au moment où vous êtes parti vous pensé
que c'était lui qui était le mieux placé
pour vous remplacer
oui mais je suis content d'être revenu
dans la campagne au leadership mais je
pense que tout le monde reconnaît qu il
était le meilleur
lui qui était même plus préparé que je
suis rattaché d'un son parcours le
destinait à chaque fonction de monsieur
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il a
apportée vraiment de particulier à la
cause souverainiste
d'abord la capacité de l'équipe de
l'exprimer d'exprimer l'accouchement de
la défense
l'amortissement et d'inspirer des
convictions
prenons les phenom ii parole d'action
impressionnantes actions étant réaliste
mais c'était aussi un homme
extraordinaire douces paroles d'une
culture d'une maîtrise la langue d'une
élégance et d'expression rarement vu
dans notre vie politique
moi j'ai donné meilleur que j'ai vu je
n'ai pas entendu de meilleur en tout cas
certainement puis sa culture générale
et puis ce sera content et très drôle le
trait quand je l'aï rencontré la
dernière fois il ya quelques semaines
deux ou trois semaines
finalement en avril mardi semblait pas
trop la situation y était pour beaucoup
non il n'avait pas envie de parler de sa
maladie et du drame de son existence qui
allait se terminer
non à part les politiques on en parle
déjà d échanger des anecdotes on sait
finalement il était comme ça bernard
s'était jamais banal par la banda jamais
banal et après rené lévesque après
jacques parizeau maintenant monsieur
landry est ce que la flamme
souverainiste n'est pas en train de
s'éteindre tranquillement chez moi j'ai
beaucoup moins qu'avant on peut dire
merci beaucoup monsieur du shanxi